Elsie Mills turkey from the UN refugee
agency the UNHCR tries to bring some
order to this queue of mozambican
refugees the refugees receive a number
and are then asked about their
background and the reasons for their
flight there are around 3,500 people in
luan e camp in South Malawi although
each has their own individual story
they're united by a fear of violence
flaring up again back home many have
experienced it firsthand both were
coming in recent times are coming
because they have seen vehicles army
vehicles with weapons this is what they
claim that has brought them here but
initially some of them were beaten
became the web beaten and their houses
were banks early last year the conflict
between the two sides in the country's
civil war the governing party for a limo
and the opposition rain amo escalated
again thousands fled to Malawi since
then the situation has calmed somewhat
which is why the UNHCR has initiated a
special program to help people return
home organize a go and see come until
mission this means that we will the
community will select a few individuals
from the various areas where they fled
from
they will go back there spend the night
together with us UNHCR and then we bring
them to Malawi where they come and tell
the rest of the community what they saw
phew believe the government in maputo
zhis er shins that those returning have
nothing to fear that's why the UNHCR
wants to be prepared for people staying
put a while and is keen to make their
stay in the camp more bearable so a
tense accommodates a family of five if
they are beyond they are the above five
we give them two tents and they will
they will stay here for a week or two
weeks however we currently have a
shortage of semi permanent shelters so
some of them have been here for about a
month Fatima diva son and her five
children have only just arrived in
lawanee they've been on the road for
months trying repeatedly to find shelter
in their home country it was a London
cuando what brought me here was war my
other kids were killed and my husband as
well when running away I was running
away to protect these other children so
that their lives could be spared in
Malawi Fatima doesn't want to return to
Mozambique just yet she's convinced
tensions between the former warring
parties could flare up again at any time
the UNHCR hopes that the last refugees
will be able to return home in the next
few years but with no solid guarantees
of peace or security from maputo it's
hard to imagine that actually happening